bonsoir c'est vrai que j'ai des yeux
formidablement à l'eau vous c'est quelle
couleur c'est très très beau
alors oui
donc vous vous appelez Eden Noah alors
j'ai vu dans une émission de télévision
et l'animatrice savait pas ce que
voulait dire en français alors vous non
plus d'ailleurs vous disiez fleur de
bois alors je vais vous le dire quand
même ça veut dire la bruyère voilà
bruyère vous vous appelez bruyère Noah
voilà vous avez un petit accent
pendant 25 ans
vous avez le perdre là vous l'avez déjà
beaucoup moins
vous avez moins d'accent que Jane Birkin
déjà
en France elle dit toujours le port
elle a déjà perdu sa poitrine elle peut
pas perdre son accent
alors
vous allez donc on va vous faire on va
vous faire une hypeview alors le
principe de LiveView c'est que donc on
est 1 2 3 4 5 pour vous poser des
questions vous êtes tout seul donc c'est
pas très équitable mais c'est comme ça
je vais demander à Serge calfond de
baisser la lumière est terrible
attention et voilà
alors vos yeux sont encore plus beaux
dans cette lumière alors vous êtes donc
laissez aussi
que ça soit clair dès le début j'ai pas
envie de me prendre un pain parce que
son mari est beaucoup plus fort que moi
donc alors Astrid Veillon a des amis
Corse et le mari d'eternoa est très
costaud voilà donc aujourd'hui je vais
me rabattre sur un deux trois monsieur
je passe ça va être bon alors vous vous
appelez Everest Stewart White et vos
parents étaient habités le sud de
l'Angleterre c'est ça ils étaient fermés
dans une petite ville et après ça je me
suis déménagé dans une ferme
alors quand vous étiez petit quand vous
étiez plus jeune va petite vous avez
jamais été petite justement on se
moquait de vous parce que vous étiez
grande et maigre
maximum pour grossir un peu
alors vous êtes toujours d'ailleurs
maintenant
et alors vous êtes toujours du mal à
vous habiller aujourd'hui parce que vous
trouvez pas des des vêtements aussi
mince c'est aussi long quoi
donc et les jambes je trouve pas les
pinceulant parce que chez les femmes les
pensions linge ça vient de lâche ici
donc moi j'ai pas de problème
c'est pratique en revanche on peut faire
du cheval et patins à roulettes en même
temps
alors vous avez été baby-sitter vous
avez été infirmière vous avez fait des
études de psychologie et puis mannequin
évidemment quand on vous voit on voit
pas pourquoi vous auriez pas fait
mannequin et un jour vous avez rencontré
Yannick Noah alors le problème qui est
Noah c'est qu'il a commencé à faire du
tennis à l'âge de 8 ans et donc il a pas
eu de jeunesse quoi il a il a travaillé
il s'entraîné il s'est entraîner il
s'entraîner jusqu'à ce qu'il gagne donc
effectivement il avait envie de vivre
après c'est normal parce qu'il avait
comme dit la chanson il avait oublié de
vivre et puis l'autre citer les grands
ah mais moi j'ai fait des études et il y
avait un autre problème avec Yannick
c'est laavavisme parce que son
grand-père avait 8 femmes et son
arrière-grand-père en avait 30
ans
bien sûr et donc la chance la chance de
la chance car il dort c'est que je suis
sûr qu'il nous raconte des conneries
c'est lui non c'est vrai c'est la tribu
des et Wando
camerounais à grand-père 30 mais la
chance de Eder c'est que Yannick elle
est réincarnation de son grand-père et
pas de son arrière-grand-père donc ça
donne quand même évidemment un espoir je
vous traduis pas
alors entre vous non ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'il y avait quand même au départ
des difficultés c'est l'Amérique Yannick
avait envie de s'amuser il y avait cette
hérédité donc d'avoir plusieurs femmes
et bien malgré tout depuis qu'il était
avec vous ça marche très bien depuis 7
ans c'est ce que je voulais dire
on est tranquille ensemble
est-ce que c'est pas parce que vous
voyez pas beaucoup
je pense qu'il y a une chose qui est
très importante faut pas être touché un
projet c'est bien que tu fais un petit
break de temps en temps avec notre vie
nous on battre être ensemble [ __ ] non
on est beaucoup plus ensemble que il y a
2 ans mais c'est vrai si tu fais
attention à l'autre
c'est une fête alors quand vous êtes
rencontrés lui a déclaré je me souviens
pas de la rencontre j'étais sous
mais vous vous avez vous vous en
souvenez très bien c'était dans un hôtel
à Rome c'est ça non ah oui c'est une
amie et c'est vrai
elle était en train de danser il était
un peu seul et j'étais avec une amie
Angela
mais qui c'est qui c'est le mec il m'a
même pas demandé mais elle était quand
même charmante
il vous a demandé votre numéro de
téléphone vous la fusée et lui il a dit
c'est moins facile que d'habitude donc
ça c'est un conseil que je donne à nos
amis téléspectatrices il faut vraiment
pas donner son numéro de téléphone tout
de suite sinon ça fait fille facile
voilà bah oui c'est vrai je vous le dis
à vous aussi moi
je donne pas le premier soir
et alors moi je donne nouveau
c'est quoi votre numéro de téléphone
vous êtes sur liste rouge voilà c'est un
numéro international en plus c'est très
très difficile à avoir alors il y a eu
sur liste rouge
et vous vous dites je vous dites je ne
suis pas une femme du premier soir voilà
montrer ses enfants on a passé le
week-end avec eux et c'était on n'était
pas pressé
je l'ai vu dans le journal El qui est
une très belle histoire c'est un jour
dont vous prenez un bain tous les deux
après évidemment
le flirt était fini depuis longtemps et
alors ne la sort de l'eau et il y a des
gens qui ont lu le l le non mais c'est
une très belle histoire tout le monde on
a parlé là c'est bon tout le monde en
parle là dans Paris je peux vous dire
que cette semaine tout le monde n'a pas
arrêté intellectuel ici
avec de la mousse avec
avec de la mousse sur le corps et
Eder ici présente le regard des dit my
god ce type est une statue
ça c'est genre de truc que nous si tu
veux frère
vous ça peut vous arriver ils vont beau
comme vous êtes non mais c'est pas c'est
pas très important c'est ce qui est
important c'est non mais c'est vrai ce
qui est important c'est c'est qu'il a
donné l'esprit
il aurait pu facilement quand même
tourner tête de con eu un énorme succès
très très jeune et puis il y a pas
beaucoup de tennisman avec qui j'aurais
envie de partir en weekend parce que
avec lui
donc je continue l'histoire Noah se lave
les dents vous vous êtes dans l'eau
froide comme ça et vous le regardez
fasciné je pouvais pas sauter
trop timide
quand vous racontez ça alors là ça c'est
bon en plus alors vous êtes resté six
mois avant de lui en parler un jour vous
dites écoute
intéressé très longtemps au moins une
heure dans le bain l'autre est toute
froide à la fin et donc si moi sans lui
en parler et un jour vous lui en parler
et lui il dit bah effectivement je m'en
souviens je pensais que tu étais un peu
aussi longtemps dans le bain un peu
dérangé il pensait quoi en fait vous
étiez tout simplement amoureuse de lui
c'est beau alors
tu es un peu
dérange
d'accord
alors vous avez vous avez réalisé vous
avez réalisé le rêve de toutes les
Françaises et épouser Yannick Noah qui
avait déclaré après son divorce avec
Cécilia j'avais dit que je me remarierai
jamais quoi alors une question que je
vais vous poser quand vous êtes allé
voir vos parents en lui disant j'ai
trouvé un type c'est un rasta il a des
tresses il a une barbe il est divorcé il
a deux enfants ils ont réagi comment vos
enfants
et me connaît très très bien c'était un
peu près trois semaines que je sois avec
un ou quatre semaines et c'est elle qui
me dit ah enfin tu es amoureuse de
quelqu'un elle a senti dans mon coin
donc elle a pas posé les questions comme
ça et je vais même pas besoin
d'expliquer les choses comme ça sauf que
je suis amoureuse de caca à la tête
comme toi
et je lui n'oubliez pas bien si elle est
bien
les acheter maintenant les acheter
maintenant
alors après il y a eu mariage dans un
château l'une de miel au Mexique sur une
plage déserte enfin il a tout fait il a
fait bien est-ce que c'est un événement
qui a été couvert par les journalistes
ou est-ce que il y a eu des photos non
où est-ce que ça se fait aussi beaucoup
dire à un mariage
du tout il y a pas de cassette
de tout donc vous vous retrouvez
enceinte et justement enfin votre
première grossesse je vais remontrer le
lit vous êtes resté quand même 7 mois
allongé parce que vous aviez plus le
droit de bouger zoom mon garçon zoom
zoom vous êtes resté 7 mois à langer et
alors vous saviez pas très bien comment
vous en sortir vous appelez votre mère
vous avez appelé des amis vous avez lu
tout ce que vous avez pu lire etc
première chose je me renseigne écouter
médical que j'avais mais après ça je
savais pas quoi faire avec la maladie
donc j'étais obligé de
qui était vraiment là pour le moment
pour lui donner plein de choses qu'elle
peut soigner elle-même tout ça donc j'ai
commencé à faire un collection de notes
je commençais les choses et après 2 ans
l'autre va de 2 ans je vais assez de
papier de faire un livre et je me suis
dit il faut que je fasse pour moi pour
moi et mes amis et si ça marche bien
voilà c'est là maintenant
ce que vous dites dans votre livre moi
je l'ai je l'ai lu évidemment je suis
moins concerné que que si j'étais une
femme mais je l'ai je l'ai eu des
enfants justement alors il y a un truc
que vous vous expliquez qu'on peut
rester sexy en étant enceinte vous avez
pris 15 kilos quand même hein
quand même faut pas sentir trop comme
baleine
il faut vraiment apprécier les choses il
faut respecter le changement il faut
vraiment
l'avantage ce que vous dites c'est quand
on est enceinte l'avantage quand même
c'est qu'on a des gros seins d'un coup
donc c'est pas mal aussi
tu vas pas et tu peux bien profiter de
ça
la grossesse bien sûr que ça me tente
bien sûr j'arrive à 28 ans
alors ce que vous ce que vous dites
c'est que en fait ce qu'on sait pas nous
souvent les hommes et je dis ça à
Frédéric qui est concerné au premier
chef puisque ça ça fiancé on en parlera
tout à l'heure d'ailleurs longuement
sa fiancée étant ça donc
écoute bien Frédéric écoutez bien
Frédéric vous dites que la sensibilité
féminine est augmentée en fait par la
par la grossesse c'est-à-dire que les
femmes en fait sont plus sensibles à ce
moment-là
je comprends pourquoi vous êtes restés
allongé 7 mois
et vous et vous alors vous portiez un
string ça c'est assez étonnant que vous
étiez enceinte un jour vous allez chez
le médecin et vous aviez un
Stringer le sous-vêtement pour la femme
enceinte c'est qu'ils sont moches dedans
et en fait maintenant aujourd'hui tu as
plusieurs tailles et je me suis sentie
bien que vous avez avec un string en
fait que le gros culottes
donc j'adore parler de cette truc là moi
je me régale vraiment
que j'ai un gros ventre donc je vais
mettre un string avec mon gros ventre
c'est une très bonne idée c'est pour
quand Thierry l'accouchement
alors vous avez c'est des choses qui
intéressent beaucoup nos amis
téléspectateurs parce qu'on est tous
plus ou moins perds de famille ici ou
mère de famille vous avez pas voulu
savoir le sexe du bébé avant
[Applaudissements]
le plus beauté et c'est le surprise à la
fin
c'est pas grave pourquoi vous l'avez
fait vous moi j'avais envie de savoir
parce que je suis curieux et que
j'utilise les progrès de la science
voilà je veux tout savoir si la
technologie permet de savoir c'est une
fille qui s'appelle Eugénie et vous il
vend si tu vas chez Ikea tu prends du
papier peint etc et tu choisirais rose
évidemment
alors il y a une autre question qu'on se
pose un enfant
il y a une autre question qu'on se pose
souvent il y a d'abord est-ce qu'il faut
demander le sexe de l'enfant avant et
puis aussi faut-il assister à
l'accouchement alors moi j'ai jamais été
tellement partisan de ça mais en
revanche j'ai ce qui fait que Yannick
lui avait assisté
à
l'accouchement je peux pas que la femme
soit confiture
c'est pas grave il faut pas senti
coupable que tu es pas capable d'être là
avec un camera
la famille le soir
donc il faut être
dernière question est-ce que vous
est-ce que vous avez fait la péridurale
oui à la fin un tout petit là j'ai ça
enlève le tout mais j'avais envie de
senti tout ce qui se passe avant donc en
fait je vais tout petit
donc je conseille ça c'est pas mal comme
ça tu es plus concentré plus alors vos
enfants s'appelle donc Elia
Elijah c'est compliqué elle est déjà
magnifique vous avez allaité il faut
allaiter alors dans votre bouquin
c'est quelque chose qui qui va avec
toute façon qu'on ne baby ça aussi tu
mets à la sainte tout de suite tu as pas
le choix tu vas tu vas craquer tu sais
que ça fait mal quelque chose mais
c'est les mêmes choses pour le sentier
pour le Baby bien sûr et c'est très bien
pour le moment aussi pour son
sérieux dans les boîtes de nuit c'est la
prochaine fois que vous avez draguer
quelqu'un avec ce que tu as à la maison
voilà non je voudrais savoir après la
couchement combien de temps il s'écoule
pour qu'on puisse recommencer à envoyer
ce que je veux dire faire des câlins ça
dépend
après 4 semaines ça dépend exactement ça
dépend elle va se voir
bon alors Yannick avait déjà deux
enfants Joachim et Yelena qu'il avait eu
avec Cécilia c'est une des raisons
dit-il pour lesquelles il est retourné
habité à New York ça vous avez pas peur
vous quand même vous êtes vachement vous
êtes très sûr de vous parce que
je sais pas il va habiter dans la ville
où habite son ancienne femme il se voit
bien entendu pour les enfants vous avez
pas peur vous êtes je me trouve ça un
peu
dommage que tu vois pas comment ça peut
pas marcher ça peut marcher c'est
vraiment dommage que les gens pensent
comme ça nous on est en famille ensemble
quand tu tombes amoureux de quelqu'un tu
exceptes tout ce qui est
naturel pour moi donc mes enfants aussi
c'est une partie de la famille elle y a
une mienne un mois donc
on a quelque chose en commun donc je
pense que c'est le seul moyen de faire
les choses et c'est beaucoup plus sympa
[Musique]
ils sont forts et camerounais quand même
moi j'y suis jamais arrivé
c'est à moi entre elles justement
dernière question sur Roland-Garros
commence lundi donc
Yannick Noah a gagné Roland-Garros en
1983 on s'en souvient tous il a déclaré
c'est formidable lendemain c'est le
surlendemain aussi et puis le mercredi
il y a plus rien du tout et la question
c'est est-ce comment on vit est-ce que
c'est facile de vivre quand on a son
climax derrière soi quand on a eu ce
qu'il pouvait vous arriver de plus
important dans la vie quand c'est déjà
passé est-ce comment est-ce qu'on peut
continuer à vivre quand on sait qu'on
fera jamais mieux
quand tu as bien vu
c'est pas facile parce que si tu as un
challenge quand tu arrives tu me
demandes qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
donc là il faut que tu Replonges
vraiment dans toi-même de ressentir les
choses de retrouver ton équilibre c'est
ça qu'il y a rien fait vous une question
d'Amélie Mauresmo qui va la driver pour
pour Roland-Garros je sais pas Yannick
vous êtes le bienvenu vous venez quand
vous voulez merci en tous les cas on
était ravi de faire votre connaissance
je rappelle le titre de votre livre donc
c'est pas nourrir en entendant un bébé
chez Michel Lafont
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu